the NAACP has issued a travel advisory
for Florida it says the state is quote
openly hostile toward African Americans
people of color and
lgbtq plus individuals due to a series
of measures recently signed by Governor
Ron DeSantis now they are not the first
Civil Rights group to issue this kind of
warning which comes as DeSantis prepare
as a presidential run equality Florida
and the league of United Latin American
citizens have also issued warnings Mark
Strassman has more
in Florida critics sense hostility from
Governor Ron DeSantis and his
conservative Crackdown in the state the
naacp's new message beware of traveling
to Florida why do you believe that
Florida is so hostile to Black Americans
but it's been demonstrated by the
governor's action and the policies that
have been Advanced and so we want to
make sure the rest of America understand
the hostility in which he is governing
uh in his quest to become president
DeSantis just days away from announcing
a bid for the White House has been
solidifying his conservative credentials
he's blocked public high schools from
offering an African-American studies AP
course barred all grades from teaching
about gender identity and critical race
Theory and signed a ban on abortion
after six weeks we will never ever
surrender to the woke mob is this just
politics I mean it certainly is is just
politics right but the problem is that
it impacts lives and so it may take
years for us to unwind the damage that
has been done here in Florida Heather
Wilkie leads zebra youth it provides
services to lgbtq teens and young adults
in Orlando people are so afraid because
they've seen these targeted attacks look
at what happened with Disney more
backlash from Florida's largest private
employer Disney the company and DeSantis
have feuded ever since Disney opposed a
state law critics dubbed don't say gay
just last week the company synonymous
with Florida tourism scrapped plans for
a billion dollar new campus in the state
Disney may have gotten everything they
wanted in Florida for the last 60 years
but there's a new sheriff in town now
and as for the NAACP advisory a
spokesman for DeSantis called it a stunt
and tourism in Florida is up a record
137 million tourists visit to the state
last year for CBS mornings I'm Mark
Strassman in Orlando
well I keep thinking about the black
people that live there I actually have
two sisters that live in Florida what
does what this means for people who live
there or people of color who are
planning to go to Florida I don't know
it's very unsettling to me on many
levels yeah I mean I think Rhonda's
heads is very happy to have this fight
yeah for the NAACP to say a democracy
will prevail I mean democracy is
prevailing in Florida the state
legislator legislature passed these laws
the governor signed them that's the
process he got votes from majority of
Latino voters a decent portion of the
black population there and this is the
Democracy vote them out next time